take a look at any Tesla Model 3 and try
to guess what's the most expensive part
to manufacture go ahead we'll wait it's
okay if it's not obvious because you
can't see it without tearing a Tesla
apart
investment bankers UBS ran an analysis
of such a teardown and found that the
battery makes up to 40% of the
manufacturing costs of any Model 3 the
battery has been one of Tesla's greatest
challenges in their goal to make a
vehicle that's affordable to most people
yet still profitable the ticket price
for a model 3 is currently about 40
$2,900 while the average new car in
America is selling at around $32,000 in
February mr. musk tweeted that the model
3 is down to just below $35,000 but only
if you include $8,000 in gas savings and
a tax credit that's set to expire on
July 1st the forty two thousand nine
hundred dollar ticket still puts the
model 3 outside of reach for most
consumers so we're going to take a look
at what makes the batteries and Tesla's
it's so expensive I see a Tesla I don't
see a car I see you know a battery pack
driving around this guy's is a car J
Whittaker of Carnegie Mellon University
studies the battery cells produced by
Panasonic Tesla's supplier certainly the
the first or second most expensive thing
in any of these vehicles is the battery
pack and so they are acutely interested
in shaving off every penny they can from
the cost of that pack because obviously
the vehicle market is very competitive
and they are competing with internal
combustion engine cars
he says the amount of charge a battery
holds can make a big difference in the
batteries cost the lower end of the
Model 3 can hold 50 kilowatt hours of
charge that's good for 220 miles of
driving doing that takes 2976 of fees
the Panasonic 2170 good reason to
believe that Tesla's kind of found that
sweet spot with this particular flavor
this is pretty good variation because I
think you know they're wirele adopters
or maybe the only adopter of this
particular size
it remains the most energy dense battery
suitable for electric vehicles its
namesake 21 and 70 stands for the
diameter and height of the battery which
is bigger in bulkier than the
predecessor found in the Model S the the
main thing you want to do if you want to
optimize the cost of a lithium-ion
battery cell is you want to add the
thickest electrodes you can have in any
of them so you're making fewer cells
with more energy this definitely is
gonna play out to a better cost
proposition at the other day the nuance
and materials matters
Tesla's batteries rely on a mixture of
lithium nickel cobalt aluminum and oxide
the biggest thing driving the cost was
the cobalt so Tesla and Panasonic
reduced their reliance on the element
their new battery uses more silicon
instead analyst sandy Munroe who tore
down model threes touted its battery
management system saying that Tesla is
far ahead of the competition which shows
in this chart over the last decade
batteries were projected to come in at
pretty expensive rates as much as
fifteen hundred dollars per kilowatt
hour in a vehicle with a similar range
to the Model 3 that could translate to a
$75,000 battery when contacted Tesla
wouldn't share details on its cost for
the Model 3 batteries but it's clear
that the company has consistently
entered markets well under projected
rates the red dots on this chart
represent their entries on the e V
market and a UBS estimate on Tesla's
Model 3 batteries comes in at 111
dollars per kilowatt hour that's 20
percent cheaper than the nearest
competitor but so far it hasn't been
enough to hit the thirty-five thousand
dollar mark without tax credits so the
company has looked for other ways to
optimize battery costs like scaling
production
in 2015 the automaker announced a joint
venture gigafactory
with Panasonic Tesla's website shows
that the factory is producing up to 20
gigawatt hours of new capacity each year
that includes production for other
products but there's plenty of battery
storage for cars happening there
Whitaker says that many batteries per
year maxes out their savings from a high
scale of production what our analysis
shows and we've run this a number of
times is that if you get much above
somewhere between 600 megawatt hours a
year and one gigawatt hour a year of
lithium-ion battery production in a
factory adding more things in that
factory adding more units or increasing
the throughput doesn't help you with
cost anymore however the corollary is
that if you centralize a huge amount of
production of one thing in one location
your supply chain is simplified your
logistics are simplified your manpower
distribution is simplified there's a lot
of other like overhead or exogenous
things that can be you know significant
in the overall like rundown of what it
wises cost what it costs so for now
tests will have to find some other way
to get to a true price that has wide
appeal in the States tax credits or
production line tweaks can help but
without a scientific breakthrough there
are limited ways to make big savings in
the battery for consumers that means
another generation of research is due
before EVs can really compete on price
with their gasoline-fueled
alternatives
[Music]